yo yo yo let's give this do G yes got
two oh you see that that was a triple
kill I think we've got four iPhones
we've got the iPhone 7 the iPhone 10 the
iPhone tennis Macs in the iPhone 11 pro
max so we've got the a 10 ship the a 11
the a 12 and the a 13 and we're gonna
play call of duty mobile on each of
these phones to see how the graphics
quality and settings are on each phone
and how the performance is playing call
of duty mobile so let's get right into
the gameplay so we're gonna start off
with the iPhone 7 that's packing the 810
fusion chip as you guys can see it
defaults to medium graphics quality and
medium framerate we're actually gonna
try to go to high and very high this
screen is so tiny this is like such a
small screen to compare to what I'm used
to
we've got him under if you guys could
even see anything but hey I'm I'm able
to kill these dudes oh you got me so far
it's feeling really smooth I'm actually
surprised I'm actually shocked that it's
able to play on an iPhone 7 with the
a-10 chip literally with this size
display it's so hard to see anybody can
I neither okay I'll just my phone it's
definitely not maxed out but you can
play it I mean man this is so hard to
see oh my goodness got a got him aw come
on man
got him I'm really surprised about how
optimized the game is though for Boulder
processors because this feels actually
playable if you have an old phone like
this it'll get out of here bro
yeah Adam check out this kill kill yeah
that's me right there on this old tiny
display phone now switching over to the
iPhone 10 from 2017 with the 8:11 chip
first of all I'm noticing the difference
in speaker quality much louder earpiece
speaker right here and of course you see
the the full screen edge to edge except
for that notch right there so this
definitely looks a lot better so
interestingly actually defaults to high
in high except this time I get the
option for a very high frame rate and
even max frame rates so let's go very
high on the graphics actually if we go
on very high on the graphics the max
goes away so I'm gonna go back a little
bit just to get the max frame rate
because I think that's probably the most
important thing definitely a lot easier
to play and see everything on this phone
sup nerds all right let's go
huge jump out from the 7 to the 10
everything looks so much better
yo let me shoot
yeah Adam that was weird
oh we had a minigun light a fire to
these dudes Oh Oh looks like we won
not bad I'm really surprised how
optimized this game is because even with
this 811 chip everything's working so
well even though we're not at very high
graphics quality it still looks really
good in the frame rates absolutely
perfect like no dropped frames at all
the frame rate I think is that 6000 I
got to I thought I got three guys so
close when we see that slide
yeah diem oh come on bro all right let's
do this
[Applause]
Oh got'em
Oh almost got him you guess you that ah
second place come on I was pretty good
overall really impressed with the
performance on the iPhone 10 feels
perfectly smooth with the frame rate no
dropped frames or anything really well
optimized game now switching to the
iPhone tennis max with the 1/12 Bionic
chip from 2018 as you guys can see
there's a massive difference with the
display it's just so immersive and
another difference I'm noticing is the
speakers they're just so much louder
even though the volume is set to around
50% so I'm gonna turn it down slightly
it looks like it's set to very high
graphics quality in high frame rates so
we're actually gonna hit max and
interestingly here we're actually able
to do max frame rate while at very high
graphics quality which we were not able
to do on that front end there you go
that's what I'm talking about this is
what you want to play mobile games on
this is absolutely incredible super
smooth 60fps really easy to play really
easy to see everything you trying to
snipe me broke out I saw a guy here
Oh watch this watch this got'em this is
much easier to play it's so much easier
to see people here that's the biggest
difference everything feels really
smooth but you can see everyone so
easily here yep there he is
oh that was not a triple kill that was
so close guys gotcha bro
game plays super smooth absolutely
perfect this games really optimized no
issues at all performance wise the
phones are not getting hot at all no
screen dimming nothing like that there
you go
first place to be completely honest so
far this is the best FPS game out there
on mobile these guys are good
come on friend Oh got him oh we got me
no way
so much action Oh aah got me game play
is absolutely perfect on the tennis max
now finally guys here we are on the
iPhone 11 Pro max as you guys can see
right there here it is the same display
not much has changed the front you can't
even tell it apart from the tennis max
Call of Duty has not been updated so you
actually can't do max framerate on the
iPhone 11 Pro right now until they
update it so that kind of sucks I think
this very high might be 60 FPS will
double check just to make sure all right
so far gameplay feels really smooth I'm
sure this is 60 FPS because this feels
really smooth so the differences between
the 10s and this is that the display is
brighter so I actually had to turn it
down a bit to match got him so far
everything's looking great on this phone
oh let's get this dude G yes got to
double kill right there oh you see that
that was a triple kill I think oh no yes
this is insane guys I'm just running
through these guys Oh was that the last
kill look at that we destroyed these
guys anyways gameplay feels perfect on
this phone you cannot get better
there you go first place guys on the
iPhone 11 pro max all these guys good is
it this night
wait is this guy hacking are you hacking
bro I just killed a hacker dude look at
this dude he's hacking he's hacking
come on bro you can't hack me yo get him
okay
I'm gonna watch this imma watch this
guys is he hacking let's see I don't
know he's actually alright so we just
finished playing on those four iPhones
in to my surprise the iPhone 7 was
actually able to play it pretty decently
well it was not at the best graphics or
at the best frame rate but it honestly
seemed pretty fine to me I didn't really
notice any drop frames or anything but
the worst part was the speaker quality
is low and also the display is just tiny
the iPhone 10 was a little bit of a step
up but if you're gonna be playing call
of duty mobile you definitely want the
10s max or the 11pro max you want the
plus size device because you're getting
a much more immersive display you're
getting much better battery life
especially on the iPhone 11 Pro max
because the battery life is insane on
that phone if you haven't already seen
our gaming comparison video between the
iPhone 11 Pro Max and the note 10 plus
you guys should definitely do that
because in that video we show the insane
battery life of the iPhone 11 Pro max
compared to the note 10 plus and
especially the 10s max from last year
you get so much better battery life so
thank you guys for watching hopefully
you enjoy this video if you guys did you
could click that circle above to
subscribe and check out the gaming
comparison video right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video get them are you hacking bro
[Music]
come on bro you can't hack me
get out of here bro
[Music]